the last flight out with him touching
down on British soil they probably
didn't mind the bumpy landing given the
alternative 105 British citizens and
their families were on board along with
95 European Nationals and their families
they have spent weeks at the epicenter
of the outbreak in China where tens of
thousands of people have been affected
and hundreds have died so this is home
and this is safety they're not quite out
of the woods they'll have to spend two
weeks in quarantine here in Milton
Keynes flight was the final one
organized by the Foreign Office but not
everyone made it Josh Garrett's a
teacher travelled through roadblocks on
empty streets to the airport just about
to arrive last day in Wuhan for a while
everything was set for the early morning
departure we are currently waiting to go
through customs but this was as close as
he got he failed an initial temperature
check and even though he passed the
subsequent ones Chinese authorities
would not let him board listenings were
playing that you're not on but you could
bid on but you're not on because you
feel the temperature check back then to
Wuhan and this was the transport the
only transports available at the moment
in Beijing I raised Joseph's case with
the British ambassador to China what we
hope is that we will be able to work
with him and offer him an opportunity to
join a flight from another country we've
already had British citizens own flights
from France and from New Zealand so I
know that there are other flights coming
in and we will help him to make sure
that he can leave if that's what he
wants to do still buck at my place now
in the meantime Josh must wait is quite
heart-wrenching to be honest because I
was telling my family my friends that I
was coming back I was looking forward to
going back and seeing everybody and the
announced of an area where it's quite
possibly dangerous to be in and now I'm
still here novel coronavirus has now
killed more people than SARS did back in
2003 that was a deeply traumatic
experience for China
so it's this and there is no end in
sight Beijing
of more than 20 million people still
feels deserted but they're building
hospitals here too getting ready for
worse to come
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing